this episode is brought to you by
t-mobile
America's best unlimited network
hey guys welcome to Ana's trailer come
tears the show we talked about the show
talks about other people's movies hi I'm
Spencer Shay Gilbert flanked as always
by Joe star hello and Dan Morrell hello
and we are talking today about the
Australian four empires know what a
return to the attack of the Gungan
Senate this is the final a Star Wars
movie I think that we haven't done if
you don't count like the Ewok ones and I
think the animated and the animated ones
but it's just in time for another Star
Wars movie to come out which in the
future where this video comes out you
will have already seen what do you think
Dan do you like it
I predict that I had thoughts on the
movie that others disagreed with and
that the conversation around it became
more about the differences than the good
thing safe bet there's some consensus
that is formed about return the Jedi in
the several decades since it came out
it's you know it's known as a okay like
it's nobody's not to many people's
favorite of the original trilogy I don't
think it's a bad movie by any stretch I
my hunch is that we were maybe a little
too hard on this in the honest trailer
but there's a lot to make fun of yeah
there is I mean I grew up in a time
where there were only up until 1999
where there were only three Star Wars
movies so there really wasn't any
latitude for there to be a bad one they
were all just great there was star war
they were all just start with Star Wars
was one thing and that was the thing
that was all one yeah and it was great
like 95% of the books are unreadable but
their Star Wars Star Wars yeah and so I
feel like the Jedi now that we have more
to compare and contrast it against and
there's more to Star Wars now I feel
like Jedi is now getting it's true
analysis yeah it's okay I've always
thought it was fine like when I grew up
I always liked watching the first two
more than the return of the judge yeah
now cuz there's a part that I really
love which is like the final lightsaber
duel between I love the climax that is
my favorite lightsaber fight of all the
all the movies so it leaves me like
feeling pretty good but everything up to
that it's so sequence oriented and then
it's not about like character moments or
or scenes it's like the first thirty
is like rescuing Han and then the next
45 minutes are about like Endor and the
Ewoks and like they're just these really
extended it kind of feels more like a
like an Indiana Jones movie almost where
it's it's really action II and cartoony
almost yeah it kind of feels like filler
sometimes like it's like George Lucas
had to resolve the Luke and Vader thing
and he had a really it's like he had a
really good beginning and a really good
end and then the middle is this kind of
a mishmash of just weird he's my
favorite Ewok yeah he is the tenor in a
young yeah when you sort of start
reading about this movie about how like
George Lucas you know obviously it's
it's hard to talk ill of the guy who's
self-financing these movies but I know
that he there was so much stress for him
after Empire went way over budget and
stuff like that but this movie feels
like a very like know you know like kind
of keeping the pocketbook shut as much
as he could kind of kind of movie like
he was definitely for whatever reason
terrified that he'd lose money strange
because this is there's no more
guaranteed hit than like the finale yeah
yeah at this point it's it's money
printing it's yeah but yeah this one
definitely feels like I don't know like
from literally the choice of you know it
was gonna be Wookiees or something
similar and he's like what if they were
one foot tall and cuter story reason for
it not being wookies was that like they
were - through Chewbacca been shown to
be too advanced already so like they
wanted like a lower on the technology
pole yeah species so they made him cute
anyways why don't we watch the honest
trailer for Empire Strikes Jedi and
comment on it
today's episode is brought to you by
t-mobile America's best unlimited
network that's our sponsor you saw them
earlier blew people's minds the Empire
Strikes Back challenge what you thought
a sequel could be now the last chapter
of the original trilogy takes its place
in history as the third one
Star Wars Return of the Jedi and his hot
response question hmm did you write that
in the script as a way for honest
trailers to have officially determined
that Star Wars Return of the Jedi is a
six word title you know I'll leave that
up to the judges you know it's they
allowed it so I'm gonna allow it to
there you go six words I didn't know if
you were slightly writing it that way to
be like mm-hmm but clearly that's how I
remember it sure I remember there we go
there you go all right it was honest
continue keep going sorry had to ask a
from creative visionary George Lucas and
once Spielberg Lynch and Cronenberg
passed the cheapest director he could
find Ben thumbs a film that had to live
up to impossibly high expectations and
said screw it we're making a kids movie
full of burp gags
slapstick comedy and Boba Fett going out
like Wiley coyote
finale that's almost silly enough to
make you question why your identity is
so tied to a soap opera about space
Wizards that's it
I'm a Trekkie now what does God need
with a starship the low point that was a
hand-picked yes that joke was written
it's just a clip and I was like well if
you're in the market for a dumb Star
Trek clip there's nothing better than
what does god from the end of Star Trek
not the not the only time unfortunately
this series has gotten far too ponderous
endzone but I know I can already tell
that they're gonna be people that push
back on us showing that clip from the
job palace singing thing as it's because
they're like well that's a special
edition the special editions have been
out longer now than Jedi believe it or
not the Jedi was so that Star Wars now
that Star Wars that that's George
Lucas's choice so it's Canon I mean we
go into it but I think I would wager
that now as people under 25 more people
know the special edition as Return of
the Jedi it's like look if you prefer
the originals like as they were released
theatrically
you can't buy them no you have to go the
dark web and trade a Bitcoin bag a
heroine for an altered cut so good luck
yeah I mean I think there's like one
unmastered DVD and then VHS is and
that's if you want and they set for like
the despecialized edition x' which are
amazing and but that's a whole other
thing so yeah I know there will be a lot
of people saying like well you can't
judge it by that like well George Lucas
says you can so we got literally not
allowed or can't find that we could find
if we really wonder like whoo but we
can't show the despecialized we couldn't
go off of that No
anyways let's keep going in this trailer
uh-uh never mind all your favourite
heroes have returned like Luke has grown
from naive farm boy to goth Catholic
priest Han who was already so over Star
Wars
had him frozen in case he didn't bother
to show up Leia true certainly Luke's
sister no you have well that makes this
extra weird there was very so the next
trilogy was going to be about Luke
finding sister sister that is one of the
urban well that's how he had to plant
out but then you where Mark Hamill says
that or I think it's like in his uh even
before hand in his notes and the Willis
bit Journal of the where he really did
he plan to introduce Luke's sister in
the next trilogy but he was like I'm
really tired of these films with this
we're interested that we didn't get to
see like Geena Davis as a Skywalker yeah
exactly yeah so that's the that's the
reason that Leia is sisters because
there was no other women to choose oh
wait they did people won't remember now
that one oh I just remember David Brent
from the office like they don't remember
yeah man yeah alright keep going yeah
this extra weird then plus an all-new
cast of memorable characters like her
salacious crumbs kind of fun and honk
sure why not that's a confirmation that
you're doing feel pain yeah yeah so just
something we set up our in the the new
hope one is that like wow they really do
feel emotions and and have physical
sensations by their pot and soul to
slaves and no one seems to care yeah
alright
Tatooine also and to those that would
say return the Jedi introduced Jabba the
Hutt again the issue is that he wasn't
so don't complain to us he was a wacky
comedy guy way before that in the movie
that takes place before any of these in
Phantom Menace when he MCS the podrace
he oh he falls asleep once and hi so
funny - oh god knows what they're gonna
do to him in the Han Solo oh boy
I mean okay because you know he's got
hopefully that's gonna be in it yeah
right yeah you know he's gonna be in it
oh yeah Joba young hot job 100% young
he's got a switchblade comb yeah Lucas
really really into Twilight's ex-slaves
- yeah because Sebulba has a bunch in a
Phantom Menace that are rubbing his
shoulders and fixing his toenails for
some reason and yeah hmm the Fuehrer
asked questions you asked about Tatooine
society the better I think
oh forget Alderaan look again a lot to
offer
Tatooine I guess yeah all right keep
going not before there was Jar Jar the
object of fans blind rage was the Ewoks
a race of cuddly creatures inspired by
puppy dogs bear cubs and toy sales whoo
Lucas loves so much they got to spin-off
movies to to your time
oh well free that discerning fans crazy
away the mighty empire would struggle
against a smaller poorly armed force
what do you think this is Vietnam
Afghanistan Little Bighorn the American
Revolution the Maori Ethiopia
Afghanistan again some real self
educated geopolitics experts weighing in
on that one this is a new flavor of you
that I enjoy because I was not I was
unfortunately not here I didn't I get to
witness the history lesson that you
taught about Wonder Woman mmm I love
that you're sneaking in historical facts
to these things you know
look I don't claim to be an expert but I
think that the if you look to history
there are multiple examples of
indigenous people defending what they
believe is their homeland doing very
well against a technologically superior
well-funded
force and it's weird how you can just
use broad but accurate examples combine
them humor to make a point yeah or a
joke you know you know if you're
actually interested in this you
shouldn't be watching
it through the lens of Return of the
Jedi maybe read a book it's true
yeah the novelization of Return of the
Jedi yes and then yeah so Afghanistan
the first time is referring to the
Soviet invasion of Afghanistan no one
has really six as seen in Rambo
Alexander the Great sort of but there's
a you know it's a tough place to conquer
no matter how much money and and tanks
you got so all this and more on honest
history a show I will never be doing so
to put this into words it would be what
do you think this is Rambo 3 the Patriot
I'm just trying to translate easily
digestable movie versions yeah that
would probably better yeah ok yeah just
food for thought
I mean Mel Gibson took on the British
with a tomahawk yeah come on guys you
didn't even eat two logs and then
Braveheart don't get me started on
William Wallace I'm sure we'll do that
on another eventually he was my college
roommates descended William Wallace my
college roommate was just this dude from
the sticks whose name was Wallace that
was his first name and that was the
first thing he told me when I met him I
was like well it's nice to meet you like
yeah man you ever seen Braveheart I was
like my great-grandpa it's like okay
there's so many things wrong with that
okay
hope you're good Wallace and set aside a
special place in hell where Jedi special
edition that not only adds the same bad
CG as the other two there are tons of
crap that's only there to remind you of
the prequels like gun guns
[Applause]
besa frames movie set dreams Hayden
Christensen's hey the criminal erasure
of the gub-gub song an entire generation
will grow up with that awful Jedi rocks
number but never know the brilliance of
John Williams Yub nub song for shame so
return to Star Wars with Return of the
Jedi a movie that joins Godfather 3
Terminator 3 and Spider Man 3 in the
tradition of man 3rd installments that
turned an entity to the galaxy ax into
the Skywalker family drama cemented the
kid friendly tone to the franchise and
set up Star Wars long-running love
affair with the plot of a new home a
battle station the emperor's new battle
station the Droid control ship
Starkiller base death stop we're
starting our attack run
miss teyla we could run out of space
real fast well penetrate in those
trenches I mean the desert plants like
poetry so if they rhyme rhymes with did
story my MIDI coracle romance I'm gonna
board feeling about this
Sonny Dee Williams ball sac force bad
Catholic dress MA
Sister Sister ghost dad harmonica solo
daddy sucks good night and a in this
little guy parliament trunk atelic and
star wars 3 episode 6 out of 9 I love
the raw new 12 yes just a word of advice
to Daisy Ridley if you see Lucas talking
to the wardrobe department run yeah nice
so man final thoughts should I man those
you know that you have no that's a
that's a scab you don't want picked is
just that
keep plopped in s1 think the thing just
blew up and all of a sudden on course
out there's just a big party as there's
not what would be happening
well and the thing that most people
don't get or even remember is that the
special editions came out before the
Phantom Menace came out so he added all
that stuff of like the Gungans and Naboo
and Khorasan shots of that before the
prequels came out so it's like you're
seeing now Return of the Jedi ended with
these shots on a planets that you didn't
get or like what as I kept further
specialized to that almost sure those
represented I remember see at Racal
versions that's the versions I watched
the most was the VHS triple yeah special
edition set and just I remember at the
time being very impressed by the CGI
yeah like what whoa oh cool I have no
Star Wars timeline in my head like at
this point I've seen all of these things
enough that there's just a mess of my
life that's just Star Wars stuff like I
don't remember dates or order of any now
Hayden Christensen I believe was not if
that was a post theatrical special
edition okay that was it's a they've
been monkeyed with I mean even the blue
race they monkey with him some more and
put rocks and with it weren't rocks
before there's a whole I don't even know
what they're doing anymore with them and
the note the Dexter knows were added for
the blu-ray okay what's just like why
this is ten years after that's the most
ridicule part of the Phantom Menace and
you add what is it that nothing anyway
it's dumb it's stupid I don't get it
whatever it's couldn't I say it any
better myself
dan thank you so much for being here of
course Joe well do we have a clip so we
used it all let's let's see some
outtakes oh yeah starring zat least
check it out watch the game
get back together in a daring raid to
save Han Solo from the guy Han Solo
totally ripped off tell Java
I've got his money
we're Luke since everyone he loves on a
mission as dangerous as it is
unnecessary because he's just gonna show
up and kill every one of the lightsaber
anyway but at least he gave a generation
of moisture farmers Princess Leia's
iconic slave outfit yep
nothing nerd culture loves more than a
powerful woman being reduced to the
personal plaything of a fat slug note
array if you see George Lucas talking to
wardrobe run I think that's the part we
all like and yeah it's just very plot II
it's just kind of describing yeah the
first scene of the movie no it's not
well now here you get to enjoy it yeah
yeah who's suddenly Luke's sister
reducing Luke's human female dating pool
down to one Mon Mothma story
Darth haircut Darth Sidious
Fetty plop only you can prevent forest
fires stabbington bear zoo fighters and
Di's huts storage all of these weird
people we spotted in the back that's
because we're running out of funny names
for the same character no we always have
more fun in distressed as a stormtrooper
surrendering to stormtroopers this giant
praying mantis alien we watch a whole
movie about this random Jedi and Jabba's
palace the drunkest and at the wedding
reception house dad Cthulhu and
Palpatine's purple poke pals I know
you're particularly watch Star Wars
Parenthood in his belly you will find a
new definition of pain and suffering as
you are slowly digested over
yes how can you be slowly digested over
thousands of years I mean wouldn't you
still die of old age at some point it's
a star like keeping you alive behind
your actual lifespan just to torment you
that is best up there you go
conservation yeah so yeah I guess we had
a lot of extra things of just go back
and save video starts here and yeah
people like to watch it yeah
other than that this is a very average
movie with some good things in it some
of my favourite Star Wars stuff in it
but overall yeah it's an entertaining
movie it feels like to me it feels more
like an Indiana Jones sequel it's just
like an a space adventure looks like a
great character wrap up moment at the
end with that lightsaber fight but
otherwise it's just a fun romp yeah yeah
pretty much
yeah it's fine yeah it's no last Jedi I
think I don't know where is everything
the last Jedi wasn't or it's everything
the last Jedi was or I don't know
spoiler alert we will be back next week
with another wild adventure ooh
very wild yeah and my great might be bad
after all the dice nice jacket
and as always signing off for honest
trailer commentaries this episode was
brought to you by t-mobile
switch to America's best unlimited
network
you